Alice:没杯子呢
Alice: No cups?
Alice:拿个碗吧
Alice: Let's use a bowl
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Shure: 直接倒就
Shure: Just pour it in
Shure: 倒了一点醋
Shure: Poured a bit of vinegar
Shure: 怎么样
Shure: How is it?
Shure: 评价一下吧
Shure: Give it a review
Shure: 喝不惯是吧
Shure: Can't get used to it, huh?
Alice:太酸了
Alice: Too sour
Alice:感觉跟冲的还是不一样
Alice: It feels different from the one mixed
Alice:比它好喝
Alice: Tastes better
Alice:但是你喜欢酸的吗
Alice: But do you like sour things?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后这种
Shure: And this kind...
Shure: 他能喝出来一些其他的花果香
Shure: He can taste some other floral and fruity notes.
Alice:嗯确实有点后味
Alice: Hmm, it does have a bit of an aftertaste.
Katrina: 回龙关在哪
Katrina: Where is Huilongguan?
Shure: 回龙观对
Shure: Huilongguan, yes.
Alice:在北边
Alice: It's in the north.
Alice:靠靠北
Alice: North, north.
Katrina: 哦那离离那个西直门远吗
Katrina: Oh, is it far from Xizhimen?
Shure: 离沙河远
Shure: It's far from Shahe.
Alice:离西直门
Alice: From Xizhimen...
Alice:说远不远说近不近
Alice: Not too far, not too close.
Alice:得一个多小时
Alice: About an hour or so.
Katrina: 啊这么远
Katrina: Ah, that far?
Shure: 不不到一个小时
Shure: No, not even an hour.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my god
Alice:一个吧
Alice: Just one
Katrina: 我看看啊
Katrina: Let me see
Shure: 坐十三号线就就可以
Shure: Just take the number 13 line
Katrina: 回龙观到西直门
Katrina: From Huilongguan to Xizhimen
Katrina: 8站还行
Shure: 对 31分钟
Shure: Yes, 31 minutes
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Shure: 你看看
Shure: Look at this
Alice:牛逼啊
Alice: Awesome
Shure: local我跟你讲
Alice:确实没办法我们这
Alice: There's really nothing we can do here
Katrina: 哈哈哈你们
Katrina: Haha, you guys
Alice:我们只有一个校区在村
Alice: We only have one campus in the village
Shure: 中传是吗？
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Shure: 中传在离这其实挺近
Katrina: 在昌平啊
Katrina: In Changping?
Alice:在朝阳离这很近
Alice: In Chaoyang, very close to here
Katrina: 哦哦哦中传我知道
Katrina: 我当时就定的中传附近的酒店
Katrina: 去那个环球影城来着
Katrina: To go to Universal Studios
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then
Katrina: 然后那旁边麦当劳晚上12点巨多人
Katrina: And then the McDonald's next to it is packed with people at midnight.
Katrina: 全是学生
Katrina: All students.
Katrina: 来吧家人
Katrina: Come on, guys.
Shure: 尝尝这个地道的老北京美食
Shure: Try this authentic old Beijing food.
Alice:那个郑凤是你们学校的吗
Alice:是你们学校的吗
Alice: Is it from your school?
Shure: 对没错
Shure: Yes, that's right.
Alice:对你们学校
Alice: From your school?
Katrina: 你们学校包子真有那么好吃
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 不知道他能吃32个
Shure: I don't know, he can eat 32 of them.
Shure: 我也是是个那他
Shure: I was like, wow.
Katrina: 他一个人吃32个
Katrina: He ate 32 by himself?
Shure: 我不知道他为什么点32个
Shure: I don't know why he ordered 32.
Lucia: 哎这个葡萄洗好了吗谢谢大
Lucia: Hey, are these grapes washed? Thanks a lot.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:因为如果是食堂的包子话
Alice: Because if it's from the cafeteria...
Alice:应该有那个什么补助之类的
Alice: There should be some kind of subsidy or something.
Shure: 反正就这么大的那种包子
Shure: Anyway, the buns are this big.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:什么馅啊
Alice: What filling?
Alice:有这么好吃
Alice: Is it that good?
Shure: 牛肉馅还行吧
Shure: Beef filling, it's okay.
Katrina: 拖家带口吃
Katrina: Eating with the whole family.
Shure: 我只能说我那天尝了一口
Shure: I can only say I tried a bite that day.
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you tried it?
Shure: 就是正常包子味
Shure: 没有什么特别的感觉
Shure: Nothing particularly special.
Alice:你们最近是不是开了一个什么自创
Alice: Did you guys recently open a new venture?
Alice:那个什么自那个那个文创店
Alice: Some kind of cultural and creative store?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:刷到了
Alice: I saw it online.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 郑凤那事都顶了热搜第二了天
Shure: Zheng Feng's story even topped the trending list.
Alice:撤的也挺快
Alice: It was taken down quickly.
Alice:就是一个很很很很会
Alice: He's a very... very... very manipulative mentor.
Shure: PUA学生的导师
Shure: A mentor who PUA's students. 社会问题
Alice:利用学生的一个导师
Alice: A mentor who exploits students.
Alice:他们需要的啊
Alice: They need it, you know.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:你们不知道吗
Lucia: 不知道我最近没怎么刷
Lucia: No, I haven't been checking much lately.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Alice:文娱知识
Alice: Entertainment knowledge.
Alice:不对不是不是知识
Alice: No, wait, it's not knowledge.
Alice:文娱八卦之类的
Alice: It's like entertainment gossip.
Lucia: 最近几天太忙了都没有刷这些软件
Lucia: I've been so busy these past few days, I haven't been on these apps.
Shure: 不是上上周的事
Shure: Wasn't this from a couple of weeks ago?
Shure: 就来之前的事应该是
Shure: It was probably before we came.
Lucia: ah OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Alice:你之后要去哪读书啊
Alice: Where are you going to study next?
Katrina: 我我去南京
Katrina: I'm going to Nanjing.
Katrina: 我去东南那边
Katrina: I'm going to Southeast University.
Shure: 哎有书读啊真好
Shure: Hey, it's nice to have a place to study.
Lucia: 哦原来这是肥肠
Lucia: Oh, so this is pork intestines.
Alice:让我解锁一下一种新事物
Alice: Let me unlock a new thing.
Katrina: 拿碗分是吗
Katrina: Should I get a bowl to split it?
Shure: 拿碗分吧
Shure: Yeah, get a bowl to split it.
Shure: 别一下又打了啊
Shure: Don't knock it over again.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina: 我办事
Katrina: I got this.
Shure: 这是谁谁的电脑
Shure: Whose computer is this?
Shure: 收一下吧
Shure: Put it away.
Shure: 塔莎的电脑是吗
Shure: 昨天不会来打游戏来了吧哈哈哈
Shure: Did he come over to play games yesterday? Haha.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:打完游戏抢红包贼开心
Jake: Played games and grabbed red envelopes, super happy.
Shure: 你在这打游戏来着是吗
Shure: You were playing games here, right?
Shure: 收下收下
Shure: Put it away.
Lucia: 23
Lucia: 哎我今天早上拿上来一包好像
Lucia: Hey, I brought a pack up this morning, I think.
Jake:他这有貔貅吗
Jake: Does he have a Pixiu here?
Shure: 他这个是
Shure: He's got this.
Lucia: 哎没有吗
Lucia: Hey, doesn't he?
Katrina: 没有吗
Katrina: Doesn't he?
Lucia: 那我再拿一把
Lucia: Then I'll get another one.
Jake:不是就是外外
Jake: No, it's just outside.
Shure: kitanweps
Shure: Kitanweps.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Jake:这里还有一些遗留溪秀
Jake: There are still some leftovers here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:你看
Jake: Look.
Jake:凑一凑长一长
Jake: Gather them up and make it longer.
Shure: 那筷子
Shure: What about chopsticks?
Shure: 能使吗
Shure: Can we use them?
Shure: 还要使刷一下
Shure: We need to brush it.
Tasha: 稍微冲一下吧
Tasha: Just rinse it a bit.
Alice:哪个呀
Alice: Which one?
Alice:这是
Alice: This one.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我们钱币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released.
Alice:嗯 什么
Alice: Hmm, what?
Jake:我们货币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released.
Shure: 我们的币
Shure: Our currency.
Shure: 子上链了家人们
Shure: It's on the blockchain, folks.
Jake:大家大家忘掉这件事情
Jake: Everyone, forget about this.
Jake:10年之后再想起来
Jake: Remember it in 10 years.
Shure: 然后就发现自己富了是吗
Shure: And then realize you're rich, right?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:财务自由职业自由
Jake: Financial freedom, career freedom.
Shure: 真的会吗杨老板
Shure: Will it really happen, Jake?
Tasha: 往我的账户里面先充5050个
Tasha: Put 5050 tokens in my account first.
Jake:总共150个
Jake: Total 150 tokens.
Shure: 什么时候能让我实现财富自由呢
Shure: When will I achieve financial freedom, Jake?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Jake:那就得
Jake: That will...
Alice:快的话今晚就可以
Alice: If we're quick, it could be tonight.
Jake:你
Jake: You...
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么做的这个哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, how did you make this? Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这已经开始画饼了是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, are you starting to draw a big picture already?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 少个凳子
Tasha: We're missing a chair.
Katrina: 别的笔
Katrina: Another pen.
Tasha: 再来个凳子
Tasha: Let's get another chair.
Tasha: 哦，还少一个凳子
Tasha: Oh, we're still missing a chair.
Katrina: 你看我做这个就行
Katrina: Just watch me do this.
Jake:好吃吗火烧
Jake: Are the baked buns tasty?
Katrina:  还可以
Katrina: It's fine.
Jake:好吃
Jake: Delicious.
Katrina: 这是蒸驴肉啊
Katrina: Is this steamed donkey meat?
Jake:驴肉对
Jake: Yes, donkey meat.
Jake:这就是驴肉
Jake: This is donkey meat.
Katrina: 没吃过驴肉
Katrina: Never had donkey meat before.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 要个这个就行了
Tasha: Just need this.
Tasha: 我不要筷子了
Tasha: I don't need chopsticks.
Lucia: 啊那那给给健康好了
Lucia: Ah, then let's give it to Health.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那这筷子就放这
Lucia: Then I'll just put the chopsticks here.
Jake:我我还有
Jake: I still have.
Jake:我还有一套餐具
Jake: I still have a set of utensils.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是吗这是我的啊
Jake: Really, this is mine.
Tasha: 这这还有筷子呢
Tasha: There are chopsticks here.
Lucia: 啊刚刚不是给你了一套
Lucia: Ah, didn't I just give you a set?
Jake:这是啊这不是我
Jake: This is, ah, this isn't mine.
Lucia: 笑死了我刚还以为你有两个
Lucia: So funny, I thought you had two.
Jake:我有两个人
Jake: I have two people.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Shure: 卤煮火烧
Shure: Braised buns.
Tasha: 你要吃这个是吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat this?
Jake:呃我也吃火烧
Jake: Uh, I'll also eat the baked buns.
Jake:今晚吃什么
Jake: What to eat tonight?
Jake:麦麦当劳汉堡是吧
Jake: McDonald's burger, right?
Lucia: 你们这边有了吗
Lucia: Do you guys have it here?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes.
Jake:我们吃过麦当劳汉堡吗
Jake: Have we tried McDonald's burgers?
Tasha: 没有来肯德基
Tasha: No, we came to KFC.
Jake:还肯德基
Jake: Still KFC?
Jake:第一天肯德基是吧
Jake: First day, KFC, right?
Lucia: 那我吃了
Lucia: Then I ate it.
Shure: 要加点蒜泥吗
Shure: Want to add some garlic paste?
Lucia: 有吗
Lucia: Do we have any?
Shure: 你就翻译个标题
Shure: Just translate a title.
Shure: 来是这里的
Shure: Come on, it's here.
Shure: 帮忙拿一个蒜泥
Shure: Help grab some garlic paste.
Jake: ：整点喝的上来
Jake: Bring some drinks up.
Shure: 首先倒倒倒里了
Shure: First, pour it here.
Tasha: 啊我只是想要一个娃哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I just want a Wahaha.
Jake:那你娃哈那
Jake: Then get your Wahaha.
Jake:那你待着吧
Jake: Then stay there.
Jake:你待着
Jake: You stay.
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Forget it.
Lucia: 我给你开了一瓶
Lucia: I opened a bottle for you.
Tasha: 还有谁要
Tasha: Who else wants it?
Lucia: 娃哈哈你还没喝呢
Lucia: Wahaha, you haven't drunk it yet.
Jake:是是是我想是的
Jake: Yes, yes, I think so.
Tasha: 7个人
Tasha: Seven people.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:还有个俘虏
Alice: And a prisoner.
Jake:哎肉掉了
Jake: Hey, the meat fell.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm.
Tasha: 拿个餐巾纸
Tasha: Get a napkin.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice:这个要吗
Alice: Do you need this?
Tasha: 我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my god.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Lucia: 要加得菜吗
Lucia: Want to add some vegetables?
Shure: 呃塔莎不吃
Shure: Uh, what doesn't he eat?
Tasha: 你就转换了一个芒果
Tasha: You just switched to a mango.
Lucia: 有一碗那就不加
Lucia: If there's a bowl, then no need to add.
Alice:辣椒油
Lucia: Chili oil.
Shure: 辣椒油可以整点
Shure: We can put some chili oil.
Lucia: 这是啥呀哦
Lucia: What is this?
其他人：你要娃哈哈吗
Others: Do you want Wahaha?
Shure: 我
Shure: I do.
Shure: ad钙是吗
Shure: AD Calcium, right?
Shure: 可以来一瓶
Shure: I can have a bottle.
其他人：是那个哇哈哈矿泉水
Shure: 有北冰洋吗
Shure: Is there Beibingyang?
其他人：直接有人带上来了
Shure: 我要要北冰洋
Shure: I want Beibingyang.
Jake:这卤乳是不是得有勺啊
Jake: Do we need a spoon for the braised pork?
Jake:不用了
Jake: Never mind.
Alice:你要有勺可以有
Alice: If you want a spoon, we can have one.
Jake:啊有勺
Jake: Oh, there's a spoon.
Jake:哦原来有勺可以
Jake: Oh, so we can use a spoon.
Shure: 他火上好像都在底下
Shure: It seems like everything is at the bottom.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McMcMcDonald's burger.
Jake:比什么
Jake: Better than what?
Jake:比啥玩意好吃
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Braised pork.
Shure: 招信他的杨老板
Shure: Trust him, it's Jake.
Alice:有这些料要吗
Alice: Do you want these ingredients?
Shure: 他不专业
Shure: He's not professional.
Tasha: 哦我有一个
Tasha: Oh, I have one.
Shure: 我怎么插
Shure: How do I plug this in?
Alice:哎，韭韭花
Alice: Hey, garlic chives.
Shure: 插不进去啊
Shure: It won't go in.
Alice:然后
Alice: And then...
Alice:蒜
Alice: Garlic.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:跟辣椒油
Alice: And chili oil.
Alice:应该还有个腐乳
Alice: There should also be fermented tofu.
Shure: 懂了技巧不行
Shure: Got it, the technique is off.
Lucia: 这是什么 肺子吗
Lucia: What is this? Lung?
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake:你为什么不吃卤煮
Tasha: 长的好丑啊
Tasha: It looks so ugly.
Jake:好丑
Jake: So ugly.
Shure: 你不能以貌取人
Shure: You shouldn't judge by appearance.
Lucia: 我吃到血味了
Lucia: I can taste the blood.
Jake:这丑吗
Jake: Is this ugly?
Tasha: 可他都是大肠小肠大脑小脑的感觉
Tasha: But it all feels like large intestines, small intestines, brain, and cerebellum.
Shure: 瞧不起谁呢
Shure: Who are you looking down on?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 谁没有这个东西
Shure: Doesn't everyone have those?
Alice:那你为什么把别人吃下肚
Alice: Then why do you eat them?
Jake:它有3种是吧大肠肝
Jake: There are three kinds, right? Large intestines and liver.
Tasha: 这是肺
Tasha: This is lung.
Jake:是肺肺
Jake: It's lung, lung.
Shure: 然后还有火勺
Shure: And then there's huoshao.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 火烧是什么
Tasha: What's huoshao?
Tasha: 是哪个部位啊
Tasha: Which part is it?
Jake:面啊
Jake: It's dough.
Lucia: 我也想问
Lucia: I was wondering too.
Lucia: 火烧是哪个部位
Lucia: Which part is huoshao?
Shure: 对这面块块就是火烧
Shure: Yeah, this dough piece is huoshao.
Tasha: 啊是什么
Tasha: Ah, what is it?
Jake:就驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat huoshao.
Jake:就是驴肉和火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat and huoshao.
Jake:就是驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat huoshao.
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Jake:煎驴肉就是那个东西
Jake: Fried donkey meat is just that thing.
Jake:是吧你看
Jake: Right, look at this.
Shure: 面面面饼饼
Shure: Bread bread bread.
Tasha: 这个就是
Tasha: This is it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:对用火烧出来的面
Jake: Yes, bread made by roasting.
Lucia: 好神奇啊
Lucia: So amazing.
Lucia: 出感叹
Lucia: Expressing amazement.
Shure: 孩子咳嗽老不好，多半是肺的问题
Shure: If a kid's cough doesn't get better, it's usually a lung problem.
Jake:多半是没吃过牛肉火烧
Jake: Most likely because they haven't had beef roast.
其他人：我有次吃河北人带来的卤火烧
Shure: 真的是真他妈好吃
Shure: It was really freaking delicious.
Jake:怎么带过来的就
Jake: How did they bring it?
Shure: 他带过来冷的都很好吃
Shure: They brought it cold and it was still delicious.
Jake:我去
Jake: Wow.
Jake:这3个东西
Jake: These three things.
Jake:你们用了吗
Jake: Have you used them?
Shure: 用了把蒜汁和那个辣椒油浇了就行
Shure: Yes, just pour the garlic sauce and chili oil.
Jake:用了
Jake: Used them.
Shure: 那个韭菜花一般不加
Shure: Usually don't add the chive flower sauce.
Shure: low口
Shure: Low-key.
Shure: 必须的
Shure: Absolutely.
Jake:吃啥呀腐乳
Jake: What to eat with fermented tofu?
Alice:腐乳
Alice: Fermented tofu.
Jake:腐乳加吗
Jake: Add fermented tofu?
Shure: 腐乳不加
Shure: Don't add fermented tofu.
Jake:不加好
Jake: Don't add it, okay.
Shure: 也可以尝试
Shure: You can try it.
Shure: 但我没加过
Shure: But I haven't added it before.
Shure: 我不够local
Shure: I'm not local enough.
Jake:咱要不顺势把豆汁撒在床上
Jake: Should we just spill the mung bean juice on the bed?
Lucia: 我们买豆汁了吗
Lucia: Did we buy mung bean juice?
Tasha: 买了一瓶吧
Tasha: Bought a bottle, right?
Alice:不是买了一瓶吗
Alice: Didn't we buy a bottle?
Jake: 走来
Jake: Come on.
Jake:先说要吃完吗
Jake: First, do you want to finish it?
Jake:别的吃不了
Jake: Can't eat anything else.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Lucia: 吃饱了再喝那个不是危险性更大吗
Lucia: Isn't it more dangerous to drink that after eating?
Lucia: 哈哈哈说这么直白干什么
Lucia: Haha, why are you being so blunt?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 已经要吐了
Tasha: I'm about to throw up
Shure: 我不吃
Shure: I won't eat
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 我喝过
Shure: I've drunk it before
Lucia: 我没吃过
Lucia: I haven't eaten it
其他人：我怕吃完咱们ego没了
Alice:节奏
Alice: Rhythm
其他人：下午直接倒了
Tasha: 那次在街头买了一一袋
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:街头一袋
Shure: 就是这个火
Shure: This fire
Shure: 这个活
Shure: This job
Alice:我们同学3个人去
Alice: Three of our classmates went
Shure: 必须我来干
Shure: I have to do it
其他人：私房货币的事情给给别人做
Tasha: 当时说是什么味来着
Tasha: What did it taste like again?
Tasha: 反正中午吃的全部都吐了
Tasha: Anyway, I threw up everything I ate at noon
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright
Lucia: 听起来好危险
Lucia: Sounds so dangerous
其他人：这个真的会让我们几十看后财务自由
Others: This will really make us financially free in a few decades
Jake:这个怎么怎么炒啊
Jake: How do you even cook this?
Shure: 你相你相信30年后财务自由
Shure: Do you believe in being financially free in 30 years?
Shure: 不相信你能活到30年
Shure: I don't believe you'll live to 30 years
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 我应该差不多吧
Shure: 50岁我还活不到吗
Shure: Can't I make it to 50?
Shure: 那差不多
Shure: That's about right
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 而且还要考虑通货膨胀因素
Lucia: And you have to consider inflation
其他人：金币很珍惜
Others: Gold coins are very precious
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
其他人：就是只有150个
Others: There are only 150 of them
Shure: 到时候要是马斯克看上了马斯克
Shure: If Musk takes interest in them
Shure: 再配上发一句话
Shure: And says something about it
Tasha: EGO币
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 那就得
Lucia: Then it’s settled.
Lucia: 这个监制的任务就得交给杨老板了
Lucia: Jake, you’ll take on the producer’s role.
Shure: 有一天就是大一的时候
Shure: One day during our freshman year...
Jake:是发150个币
Jake: We are issuing 150 coins.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yep.
Shure: 大一的时候张晨他晚上睡得很晚
Shure: During our freshman year, Zhang Chen stayed up really late.
Tasha: 真的吗
Jake: Really?
Jake:真的吗
其他人：然后张一晨在刷推特
其他人：看见了马斯克说屎币
其他人：你知道那个币吗
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 妈的张一晨当时就 刷到了
Shure: Zhang Chen saw it right away.
其他人：其实其实我没睡
其他人：但是他以为我睡
其他人：他没跟我说那个时候在
Shure: 那个时候在地下都没那
Shure: 个使劲都没上大交易所
Shure: 马上他直接下了个小小交易所
Shure: 赶快买了2,000的
Shure: 屎币交钱就变8,000
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：之前和张一晨在宿舍挖以太坊
其他人：挖了个小一点
Lucia: Mined a smaller one.
其他人：然后显卡挖机了
Lucia: Then used a GPU mining rig.
Shure: 我去维修的时候
Shure: When I went to fix it...
其他人：我去维修的时候人家问我你这显卡为什么两道黑杠
Jake:有什么卡吗
Jake: Do you have any cards?
其他人：3060
Jake:就就我给你了哈哈
Jake: I gave you one, haha.
其他人：不不不不       卡   拿我笔记本
其他人：你那是2060
Others: You have a 2060.
Shure: 哦2060
Shure: Oh, 2060.
Shure: 2060  钛
Shure: 没有，没有带 笔记本
Shure: No, I didn't bring a notebook.
其他人：然后那个修电脑人就很不可思议地说
Lucia: 说我就是玩游戏打英雄联盟打多了
Lucia: said I played too much League of Legends.
Shure: 打英雄联盟打多了
Shure: 其实24小时挖矿挖的
Shure: Actually, it's from mining 24/7.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 那你们宿舍电不会耗很快吗
Lucia: Doesn't your dorm run out of electricity quickly?
Shure: 所以那两个月追着我和付电费
Shure: So for those two months, I kept asking my nephew to pay the electricity bill.
Katrina: 因为那段时间呢
Katrina: Because during that time,
Shure: 那段时间电太值钱了
Shure: Electricity was so expensive.
Shure: 电费已经完全耗了
Shure: The bill was completely used up.
Shure: 就大概是三三月份挖的吧
Shure: 五月份
Shure: By May,
Shure: 国家就出台了这政策
Shure: The government released this policy,
Shure: 然后就腰斩
Shure: And then it just halved.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：这种虚拟货币就不稳定
其他人：国家就应该制止
Shure: 确实哈哈哈
Shure: Indeed, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 这都是泡沫经济
Shure: It's all a bubble economy.
其他人：直接想直接炒鸡
Shure: Just want to fry it up.
Shure: 标签打成危险
Shure: Tag it as dangerous.
Jake:就是网管
Jake: It's just a network manager.
Jake:基本上就干这个
Jake: Basically doing this job.
Jake:就是计个时间
Jake: Just keeping track of time.
Jake:哈哈哈要举报
Jake: Hahaha, need to report it.
其他人：不知道你们记不记得那个天津那个人
其他人：也没酒驾
其他人：就喜欢撞人那种事
其他人：架桥上撞人
Shure: Crashing into people on bridges.
其他人：感觉全是炒币炒的
Lucia: 决定到这边来加一个
Lucia: Decided to come here and add one.
Lucia: 还挺好吃的嗯
Lucia: It's pretty tasty, yeah.
Shure: 第一次吃啊
Shure: First time eating it?
Lucia: 对没吃过
Lucia: Yeah, never had it before.
其他人：你以前吃肥肠吗
Lucia: 肥肠我吃过
Lucia: I've eaten pork intestines before.
Lucia: 放在面里当浇头的那种
Lucia: Like those put in noodles as a topping.
Alice:那你可能也会吃炒肝
Alice: Then you might also eat fried liver.
Lucia: 说北京的那种炒肝吗
Lucia: You mean the Beijing-style fried liver?
Lucia: 啊我不喜欢那个
Lucia: Ah, I don't like that.
Alice:你不喜欢
Alice: You don't like it?
Alice:那个特别咸
Alice: That one is really salty.
Lucia: 是不是我去的地方不对呀
Lucia: Maybe I went to the wrong place?
Lucia: 我觉得特别咸
Lucia: I find it really salty.
Alice:可能是炒干
Alice: Maybe it's the fried liver.
Alice:还没这个咸呢
Alice: It's not as salty as this.
Alice:就比这个会淡一点点
Alice: It's a bit milder than this.
Lucia: 下次再试试
Lucia: I'll try it again next time.
Alice:感觉炒肝
Lucia: 对它是一种黏糊糊的
Lucia: Yeah, it's kind of sticky.
Lucia: 是吧像放了布丁粉一样的感觉
Lucia: Right? Like it has pudding powder in it.
Alice:感觉是藕粉的那种清晰
Alice: Feels like lotus root powder.
Lucia: 嗯对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:是什么呀辣椒
Jake: What is it, chili?
Alice:辣椒油
Alice: Chili oil.
Alice:韭花酱
Alice: Leek flower sauce.
Alice:咸
Alice: Salty.
Jake:那我多蘸多加点汤是吧
Jake: Then I'll dip more and add more soup, right?
Alice:你直接倒吧
Alice: Just pour it directly.
Jake:直接倒 吧
Jake: Pour it directly?
Alice:我想吃那个
Alice: I want to eat that.
Tasha: 多米诺骨牌
Tasha: Dominoes.
Jake:你这吸管咬得可以
Jake: You really chewed that straw.
Jake:他这吸管
Jake: Look at this straw.
Tasha: 没有跟我一样
Tasha: Not as much as mine.
Jake:好像没有
Jake: Seems like not.
Lucia: 我一般都是喝完了才有
Lucia: I usually chew it after finishing my drink.
Jake:咬的很有艺术感
Jake: Chewed it artistically.
Tasha: 这是一种领地意识
Tasha: This is a sense of territory.
Tasha: 导致没有第二个人
Tasha: Which leads to no one else
Tasha: 想喝我的饮料哈哈哈
Tasha: wanting to drink my beverage, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:你会喝羊杂汤吗
Alice: Do you drink lamb offal soup?
Lucia: 我喝过
Lucia: I've drunk it before.
Alice:喜欢吗
Alice: Do you like it?
Lucia: 取决于他做的好不好
Lucia: Depends on if it's made well.
Jake:喝什么哦
Jake: Drink what?
Alice:羊杂汤
Alice: Lamb offal soup.
Lucia: 我感觉有的做的还确实还行
Lucia: Lamb offal soup, I think some of it is actually quite good.
Lucia: 有的做的不好吃有点腥
Lucia: Some don't taste good, a bit gamey.
Jake:泡馍用的吗
Jake: Is it used for soaked bread?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 其实像这里面这个肺我就不是特喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I don't really like the lung in it.
Lucia: 因为我刚吃了一块饭
Lucia: Because I just ate a piece of rice
Lucia: 他有雪块味
Lucia: and it tasted like blood clots.
Lucia: 我就没再吃了
Lucia: So I didn't eat anymore.
Lucia: 但是其他的都很好吃
Lucia: But everything else is really tasty.
Alice:腥好吃啊
Alice: The gamey taste is good.
Lucia: 对腥好吃
Lucia: Yeah, gamey is good.
Lucia: 腥没有味道
Lucia: Gamey has no flavor.
Lucia: 而且很有嚼劲
Lucia: And it's very chewy.
Alice: 比较韧
Alice: It's quite chewy.
Jake:咱这豆汁什么时候喝呀
Jake: When are we drinking this soy milk?
Jake:明天后天谁买的
Jake: Tomorrow or the day after, who bought it?
Shure: 我不知道
Jake:哈哈哈这是你吗
Jake: Hahaha, is this you?
Shure: 反正谁买谁喝啊
Shure: Anyway, whoever bought it drinks it.
Lucia: 谁买
Lucia: Who bought it?
Alice:谁买谁可以指定喝
Alice: Whoever buys it can designate who drinks.
Tasha: 谁买的
Tasha: Who bought it?
Jake:谁花钱谁喝酒
Jake: Whoever spends money drinks alcohol.
Lucia: 谁指定喝可爱酒
Lucia: Whoever designates drinks cute alcohol.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This works.
Jake:你开了吗
Jake: Did you start it?
Shure: 他得冲一会儿
Shure: It needs to soak for a while.
Shure: 然后还好还显示low BATTERY
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 超市里这种豆汁
Lucia: This kind of fermented bean juice in the supermarket...
Lucia: 会不会做一些口味上的改良啊
Lucia: Will they make some flavor improvements?
Lucia: 要不然话不就没人买吗
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would buy it.
Tasha: 对啊肯定是这样子
Tasha: Yeah, definitely.
Alice:thank you
Alice: Thank you.
Lucia: hello  酷狗
Lucia: Hello, KuGou.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 直接切到这里
Shure: Cut directly to here.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What is it?
Alice:火烧
Alice: Fire roasted.
Katrina: 好久没搞了
Katrina: Haven't done this in a long time.
Katrina: 已经吊牌很久了
Katrina: It's been hanging for a long time.
Katrina: 废话
Katrina: No kidding.
Tasha: 我发现北方的馒头都不行
Tasha: 就是特别硬的那种
Tasha: They are just really hard.
Alice:我们家做馒头老用死面
Alice: Our family always makes buns with dead dough.
Alice:我就不爱吃馒头
Alice: I don't like eating buns.
Tasha: 那我爱吃活面馒头
Tasha: I love buns made with active dough.
Alice:其实也不是死的
Alice: Actually, it's not completely dead.
Alice:有发酵但是比较邦邦硬比较实
Jake:哎这怎么开
Jake: Hey, how do you open this?
Jake:这是要干啥
Jake: What is this for?
Shure: 不是我开的
Shure: I didn't open it.
Jake:为什么在动
Jake: Why is it moving?
Jake:遥控器在哪
Lucia: 我记得还有一个鹅是怎么弄的来着
Lucia: I remember there's another one, how did we do it?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 是不是很好玩
Lucia: Isn't it fun?
Lucia: 还有这个这个
Lucia: And this one, this one.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: AI你学会了吗
Lucia: Oh no, did you learn it?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Jake:哎这个像鸽子
Jake: Hey, this looks like a pigeon.
Katrina: 快断气了
Katrina: It's almost out of breath.
Lucia: 这个是大雁吗
Lucia: Is this a goose?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Jake:这是两只手
Jake: These are two hands.
Jake:哈哈哈这啥呀这是你
Jake: Hahaha, what is this, is this you?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你好AI啊
Alice: Hahaha, you look like AI.
Alice:蛇怎么弄啊
Alice: How do you make a snake?
Lucia: 不会哎有点像你说那种会吐吐吐
Lucia: I don't know, kind of like the one that goes hiss hiss hiss.
Lucia: 那个什么呢
Lucia: What's that?
Jake:鸵鸟
Jake: An ostrich.
Jake:孔雀
Jake: A peacock.
Lucia: 嘿嘿
Lucia: Hehe
Tasha: 这像不像鹿
Tasha: Does this look like a deer?
Lucia: 哎像的像的
Lucia: Yeah, it does.
Jake:鸡冠头
Jake: A rooster's crest.
Lucia: 为什么咱俩同一个手势
Lucia: Why are we making the same gesture?
Lucia: 你就是鹿而我是孔雀哈哈哈
Lucia: You're a deer and I'm a peacock, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 我记得我以前还会弄
Lucia: I remember I used to be good at this.
Alice:嘿眼珠会动
Alice: Hey, the eyeballs move.
Lucia: 哎好看
Lucia: Hey, it looks nice.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:这石头
Jake: This stone.
Lucia: 这猫
Lucia: This cat.
Jake:石头
Jake: Stone.
Lucia: 猫
Lucia: Cat.
Alice:正在思考人类为什么要
Alice: Thinking about why humans...
Jake:一个山
Jake: A mountain.
Tasha: 有什么作用
Tasha: What's its use?
Jake:山洞
Jake: A cave.
Lucia: 哪 里
Lucia: Where?
Jake:最左边
Jake: On the far left.
Lucia: 不会了小时候会好多
Lucia: I can't do it anymore, I used to know a lot as a kid.
Lucia: 我现在就只记得这个和这个狗汪汪
Lucia: Now I only remember this one and the barking dog.
Alice:会咬人吗
Alice: Will it bite?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:enough
Alice: Enough
Shure: 给大家表演一个天狗
Shure: Let me show you a celestial dog
Lucia: 给大家表演一个天狗吃月亮月亮呢
Lucia: Let me show you a celestial dog eating the moon, where is the moon?
Jake:月亮
Jake: The moon
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:哈哈这个
Jake: Haha, this
Lucia: 好像好像驴
Lucia: It kinda looks like a donkey
Tasha: 哈这是什么
Tasha: Haha, what is this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:螃蟹这是
Jake: This is a crab
Jake:这是螃蟹这是螃蟹
Jake: This is a crab, this is a crab
Lucia: 有点像再多两条腿就
Lucia: It kinda looks like it, if it had two more legs
Tasha: 这是龙吗
Tasha: Is this a dragon?
Jake:给你加俩
Jake: I'll add two for you
Shure: 这是狗
Tasha: 狗
Tasha: Dog
Tasha: 这是东邪西毒的狗吗
Tasha: 啊蝴蝶
Tasha: Ah, butterfly
Lucia: 啊原来如此
Lucia: Ah, I see
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 这是不是要那个傻吊
Lucia: Is this the silly one?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 我好处是
Tasha: My advantage is
Lucia: 国际友好手势
Lucia: International friendly gesture
Lucia: 这是兔子
Lucia: This is a rabbit
Tasha: 这是美羊羊
Tasha: This is Mei Yangyang
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈喜羊羊
Jake: Hahaha, it's Xi Yangyang
Shure: 美羊羊美羊羊
Shure: Mei Yangyang, Mei Yangyang
Lucia: 我真是美羊羊
Lucia: I really am Mei Yangyang
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 美羊羊美羊羊
Shure: Mei Yangyang, Mei Yangyang
Lucia: 哈哈可还行
Lucia: Hahaha, it's okay
Lucia: 好饱哦
Lucia: I'm so full
Jake:你的怎么也没有
Jake:看看你的是不是
Lucia: 内存满了
Jake:看一看你是不是没有开
Jake:还是你每次要摁一下
Jake:它得亮着它才
Jake:你看一看
Lucia: 您这个条他都没变化的
Jake:那就电多
Jake:可以看一下手机是不是在前进
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: IC就是手机上看这个电池电
Jake:对对对对是的
Jake:他电怎么样还
Jake:没连上
Lucia: 那他怎么
Lucia: Then what about him?
Jake:关了再开
Jake: Turn it off and on again
Lucia: 我手机快没存储空间了
Lucia: My phone is running out of storage
Jake:清掉
Jake: Clear it
Lucia: 我存了好多素材不能加
Lucia: I saved so much material, I can't add more
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:导出来
Jake: Export it
Lucia: 啊他确实在charging 98%
Lucia: Ah, it's really charging at 98%
Lucia: 早上怎么还好像还是100%呀
Lucia: How come it was still 100% this morning?
Lucia: 他是不是充的没有他耗的快呀
Lucia: Is it charging slower than it's draining?
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's okay, it's okay
Jake:一个小时下减20%可以接受了哈哈哈
Jake: Dropping 20% in an hour is acceptable, haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈OK
Lucia: Hahaha, okay
Lucia: 那么有人喝豆汁吗
Lucia: So, anyone wants some fermented bean drink?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Jake:可以晚一些
Jake: Maybe later
Lucia: 你喝过吗
Lucia: Have you tried it?
Jake:我喝过
Jake: I've tried it
Lucia: 你喝过啊
Lucia: You've had it before?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 可是你看起来
Lucia: But you look like
Lucia: 好像他并没有任何心理阴影的样子
Lucia: It doesn't seem like you have any mental shadows
Shure: 喂喂爹
Shure: Hey, hey dad
Jake:呃就大不了吐了吧
Jake: Uh, at worst, just throw up
Shure: 你说那个
Shure: You mean that
Jake:哈哈哈多大事吧哈哈
Jake: Haha, it's not a big deal, haha
Shure: 帮我把电脑开一下呗
Shure: Can you turn on the computer for me?
Lucia: 不是情绪怎么这么稳定啊
Lucia: How are you so emotionally stable?
其他人：刚刚不是开过了吗
Others: Didn't you already turn it on?
Shure: 但是你没有解锁
Shure: But you didn't unlock it
Lucia: 情绪怎么这么稳定啊
Lucia: How are you so emotionally stable?
其他人：你不是要远程吗
Others: Aren't you going to remote in?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人 ：我就没没给你关
Others: I didn't turn it off for you
Lucia: 卡皮巴拉转世
Lucia: Reincarnated capybara
Shure: 你得解锁完才能
Shure: You need to unlock it first
Jake:吐一下怎么了哈哈哈
Jake: What's wrong with throwing up, haha
Lucia: 哈哈你说到卡皮巴拉
Lucia: Haha, speaking of capybara
其人也：哎呀
Others: Oh dear
Lucia: 我这里有一个特别可爱的表情包
Lucia: I have a super cute sticker here
Jake:我我要学
Jake: I want to learn
Jake:一下这到底是个什么玩意
Jake: What the heck is this thing
Lucia: 哦我给你看
Lucia: Oh, let me show you
Lucia: 我发给你我发给你
Lucia: I'll send it to you, I'll send it to you
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 你在哪呢
Lucia: Where are you?
Jake:我真不知道
Jake: I really don't know
Shure: 然后帮我把那个向日葵拆开
Shure: And then help me open that sunflower
Jake:在这在这在这在这
Jake: Here, here, here, here
Lucia: 找不着你了
Lucia: Can't find you
Lucia: 不是我给你看那个表情包
Lucia: No, let me show you that sticker
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 在这找到你
Lucia: Found you here
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: It's
Lucia: 这个是这是这这个吧
Lucia: This one, this one, this one, right?
小薇 ：对对对对
Tasha: Yes, yes, yes
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This
Lucia: 我从我朋友那里捞来的一个表情包
Lucia: I got this meme from my friend.
Lucia: 就特别可爱
Lucia: It's really cute.
Lucia: 下午好有什么倒忙是我能帮的吗哈
Lucia: Good afternoon, is there anything I can help with?
其他人：你要远程打游戏
Others: You want to play games remotely?
Jake:有什么倒忙是需要我能帮的吗
Jake: Is there anything you need help with?
Shure: 我打打打
Shure: I'll play, I'll play...
Shure: 屁游戏我看一眼啊
Shure: What game, let me take a look.
Lucia: 哈就这个动物
Lucia: Haha, it's this animal.
Shure: 我看一下
Shure: Let me check.
Lucia: 它情绪特别稳定
Lucia: It has a very stable mood.
Jake:这个是它
Jake: This is it.
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Jake:为什么叫
Jake: Why is it called...
Shure: 可以了没问题
Shure: It's fine, no problem.
Jake:它的学名就叫这个名字
Jake: Its scientific name is this name.
Lucia: 它学名就叫卡皮巴拉吧好像
Lucia: I think its scientific name is capybara.
Alice:他叫水豚
Katrina: It's called capybara.
Shure: 阿里嘎斗
Shure: Arigato.
Jake:水豚那为什么叫巴拉
Jake: Capybara? Then why is it called "bara"?
Jake:巴拉是什么
Jake: What is "bara"?
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Lucia: 英语翻译过来好像
Lucia: The English translation seems...
Alice:就是有个有个BGM老跟他视频
Katrina: In English, there's always a BGM with it in videos.
Shure: 你滚你滚
Shure: You go away, go away.
Shure: 你别开别瞎开
Shure: Don't just randomly turn it on.
Lucia: 哦他
Lucia: Oh, he...
Lucia: 好像他英语就叫卡皮巴拉
Lucia: It seems like in English, it's called capybara.
Shure: 好拜拜
Shure: Alright, bye.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 有个BGM总是这样配的
Lucia: There's always a BGM like that.
Jake:它为什么是水豚
Jake: Why is it called capybara?
Jake:它是在水里的吗
Jake: Is it because it lives in the water?
Jake:是的是它怎么
Jake: Yes, how does it...
Alice:是的是但是它可以穿
Katrina: Yes, it can live in water.
Lucia: 的是他
Lucia: Yes, he...
Lucia: 超可爱我觉得好像小马
Lucia: So cute, I think it's like a little pony.
Lucia: 10级冲浪大师
Lucia: Level 10 surfing master.
Katrina: 一天 24小时
Katrina: 24 hours a day.
Katrina: 不对 28小时上网
Katrina: No, 28 hours online.
Lucia: 28小时上网
Lucia: 28 hours online.
Lucia: 我们这里的AI好多呀
Lucia: We have so many AIs here.
Lucia: 全天候在线
Lucia: Online 24/7.
Jake:只是插根网线
Jake: Just plug in a cable.
Jake:就我们插的是电线他插的是网线
Jake: We plug in a power cable, it plugs in an internet cable.
Shure: 跟我的云服务器已经同步了
Shure: It has already synced with my cloud server.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不我不是AI
Lucia: No, I'm not an AI
Lucia: 我只是一只树獭
Lucia: I'm just a sloth
Jake:你是什么环境
Jake: What environment are you in?
Lucia: 哈哈哈还这个
Lucia: Hahaha, this too
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 怎么了谢宾主
Shure: What's up, thank the host
Shure: 谢斌竹刚才叫我
Shure: Qin Mingzhu just called me
Jake:他他在哪啊
Jake: Where is he?
Katrina: 没叫你啊
Katrina: He didn't call you
Shure: 他不是叫修硕吗
Lucia: 他你可你可能收到了他的无线讯号
Lucia: Maybe you received his infinite signal
Alice:他在下面真的叫你
Katrina: 没听没听他喊了
Katrina: Didn't hear him call
Jake:我也没听见好强
Jake: I didn't hear it either, impressive
Lucia: 我也没听见
Lucia: I didn't hear it either
Katrina: 你俩心灵感应了
Katrina: You two have telepathy
Jake:你们是哪个频段频段的
Jake: What frequency are you on?
Jake:多少赫兹
Jake: How many hertz?
Shure: 5赫兹
Shure: 5 hertz
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay
Shure: 我要搜啥来着啊腾讯云
Shure: What was I supposed to search for, Tencent Cloud?
Jake:我们还缺什么要买的吗
Jake: Do we need to buy anything else?
Jake:下午采购去
Jake: Going shopping this afternoon
Jake:有必要吗
Jake: Is it necessary?
Shure: 可以远程盒马的这次
Shure: We can use Hema remotely this time
Lucia: 盒马送货上门啊
Lucia: Hema delivers to your door
Jake:咱要不换一家总盒马的
Jake: Should we switch, always using Hema
Shure: 对主要盒马
Shure: Yeah, mainly Hema
Lucia: 如果是买吃的
Lucia: If it's for buying food
Shure: 算是国内唯一一个这么好用的商超
Shure: Yeah, the only really good supermarket here
Shure: 就是能和也不能说能和山姆
Shure: It can compare, well, not really compare with Sam's Club
Katrina: 现在盒马 品质下降
Katrina: Hema's quality is dropping now
Lucia: 盒马不是一直是那个谁
Lucia: Wasn't Hema always owned by
Lucia: 阿里那边的吗
Lucia: That side of Alibaba?
Shure: 阿里
Shure: Alibaba
Jake:阿里 日子不好过啊
Jake: Alibaba isn't having a good time
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it
Lucia: 今年淘宝
Lucia: This year on Taobao
Lucia: 今年年初的时候开始
Lucia: Starting at the beginning of the year
Lucia: 淘宝也一直在搞新的市场
Lucia: Taobao has been developing new markets
Lucia: 市场攻略
Lucia: Market strategies
Shure: 为什么我这个c键就输不进去呢我操
Shure: Why can't I type with the C key, damn it!
Katrina: 健身房穿这袜子哎看看这
Katrina: These socks are great for the gym, look at this
Jake:得问问他都
Jake: Should ask him
Shure: 哈哈哈哈显腿细
Shure: Hahaha, they do make your legs look slimmer
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake:买啥呀买啥呀
Jake: What should we buy?
Tasha: 买买水果
Tasha: Buy some fruits
Tasha: 买淡奶油
Tasha: And buy some cream
Katrina: 谁会喜欢55岁老头啊
Katrina: Who would like a 55-year-old guy?
Katrina: 嘿嘿好帅
Katrina: Haha, so handsome
Katrina: 陶喆好帅啊
Katrina: 我有恋老癖
Katrina: I have gerontophilia
Katrina: 你看这这像55岁的吗
Katrina: Look at this, does he look like he's 55?
Jake:这谁呀
Katrina: 陶喆
Katrina: David Tao
Katrina: 我有恋老癖
Katrina: I have gerontophilia
Shure: 感觉我55岁差不多这个样子
Shure: I feel like I'll look like this when I'm 55
Shure: 迷倒一片老太太
Shure: Captivating all the old ladies
Katrina: 你55岁在抱着那吉他上人民公园
Katrina: You at 55, holding that guitar in People's Park
Katrina: 去唱摇滚去哈哈哈
Katrina: Singing rock and roll, hahaha
Jake:靠那5个ego币
Jake: Five of those for one coin
Katrina: 啊哈哈你说我有5个ego币
Katrina: Haha, you said I have five dogecoins
Jake:活下活下半身
Jake: Live half of your life
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:活下半身
Jake: Live half of your life
Katrina: 以后相亲简历上面写
Katrina: Write it on your dating profile
Katrina: 本人有5个ego币
Katrina: I have five dogecoins
Shure: 这边开着两个远程桌面
Shure: Running two remote desktops here
Katrina: 怎么这么困呢今天
Katrina: Why am I so sleepy today?
Shure: 睡
Shure: Go to sleep
Jake:BGM吗这是
Jake: Is this the BGM?
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah ah
Alice:北京野生动物园
Alice: Beijing Wildlife Park
Alice:不是有那个卡皮巴拉吗
Katrina: 对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah
Alice:好多人去跟他合影
Alice: A lot of people go take photos with him
Alice:就拿个水果啊啥顶在他的头上
Alice: They put some fruit or something on his head
Alice:反而他也不动
Alice: But he doesn't move
Alice:就是活也可以不死
Alice: He can live or die, it doesn't matter
Lucia: 不活也行
Lucia: Not living is fine too
Alice:哈哈哈活着也行死了也行
Alice: Hahaha, living is fine, dying is fine too
Alice:随便你就你这种精神状态
Alice: Whatever, with your state of mind
Lucia: 领先人类100年
Lucia: You're a hundred years ahead of humanity
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:放个榴莲在头上
Jake: Put a durian on his head
Alice:哈哈顶橘子就橘子上面再放橘子
Alice: Hahaha, put an orange and then another orange on top
Shure: 榴莲好像他顶着有点费劲
Shure: Durian might be a bit too much for him to hold
Alice:就像顶杂技一样
Alice: Like a balancing act
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh oh oh
Alice:就不不动不管
Alice: He just doesn't move, doesn't care
Alice:淡淡的死亡感
Alice: A faint sense of death
Alice:活着也行不活也行随便你
Alice: Living is fine, not living is fine, whatever
Alice:下午什么安排
Alice: What's the plan for the afternoon?
Alice:买东西
Alice: Shopping
Alice:估计快递也快到
Alice: The delivery should be arriving soon
Jake:拆快递
Jake: Unbox the delivery
Jake:你们拆快递
Jake: You guys unbox it
Lucia: 然后布置
Lucia: And then decorate
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys
Lucia: 然后收拾
Lucia: And then clean up
Alice:该布置了
Alice: Time to decorate
Jake:布置那个问答
Jake: Set up the Q&A
Alice:还要收拾
Alice: And clean up
Jake:问答的话GPT得干活啊
Jake: For the Q&A, GPT has to do the work
Lucia: GPT出完我们来检查一下吧
Lucia: After GPT finishes, we'll check it
Lucia: 要不然他胡说八道
Lucia: Otherwise, it might talk nonsense
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Jake:每天都让他有一个胡说八道的机会
Jake: Give it a chance to talk nonsense every day
Lucia: 每天都
Lucia: Every day
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, that's right
Alice:还是不知道为什么
Alice: Still don't know why
Alice:那个什么一多少来着
Alice: What was that number again?
Jake:132132 是回文数
Jake: 132132 is a palindrome.
Lucia: 132为什么是回文数
Lucia: Why is 132 a palindrome?
Alice:还有那个为什么代表3月21
Alice: And why does it represent March 21?
Jake:也没整明白
Jake: I don't quite get it either.
Alice:为什么能用16多少来着代表
Alice: Why can 16 something represent it?
Jake:对这真是太离谱了这个
Jake: Yeah, that's really absurd.
Lucia: 16几来着
Lucia: 16 what?
Alice:161 还是161吧
Alice: 161, maybe it's 161.
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Ah, seems like it.
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: But why?
Jake:是这么说的
Jake: That's what they said.
Jake:他是说
Jake: He said...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Um...
Jake:他是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said.
Jake:161 这个数字代表国际植树节3月21号
Jake: 161 represents the International Arbor Day on March 21.
Jake:尽管他与世界第九日不是同一天哈
Jake: Even though it's not the same day as World Day 9.
Alice:哈哈哈那我是不是还能代表328
Alice: Hahaha, so can I represent 328 then?
Alice:尽管他们不是同一个数字哈哈哈
Alice: Even though they are not the same number, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:是这么回事哈哈哈
Jake: That's how it is, hahaha.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 他哪怕把那个3月21除以2我都能接受
Lucia: Even if he divides March 21 by 2, I could accept that.
Lucia: 他给了一个什么奇怪的东西
Lucia: But he gave some strange thing.
Jake:139 这个数字
Jake: The number 139.
Jake:象征着地球大气中主要气体的数量
Jake: It symbolizes the number of main gases in Earth's atmosphere.
Lucia: 是139种吗
Lucia: Are there 139 kinds?
Jake:我觉得不是
Jake: I don't think so.
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Lucia: 不是一共就那么几种吗
Lucia: Aren't there just a few types?
Jake:他应该是组
Jake: It should be groups.
Alice:他说气体数量
Alice: He said the number of gases.
Jake:组了一个什么CO2
Jake: Grouped into something like CO2.
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is that?
Jake:192
Jake: 192.
Jake:这个数字
Jake: This number.
Jake:可以象征全世界
Jake: Can symbolize the whole world.
Jake:大概有192个国家
Jake: There are about 192 countries.
Alice:元素
Alice: Elements
Jake:需要参加世界第九日的活动
Jake: Need to participate in the World Day Nine event
Jake:这是是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Lucia: 只有192个国家
Lucia: Only 192 countries
Alice:一共
Alice: In total
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know
Jake:得200多吧我感觉
Jake: I feel like it should be over 200
Lucia: 好像吧有的没资格参加吗
Lucia: Maybe, are there some that are not eligible?
Alice:有的没资格参加吗
Alice: Are some not eligible?
Alice:这意思吗
Alice: Is that what it means?
Lucia: 没加入联合国吗
Lucia: Not part of the UN?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈不知道啊
Lucia: Hahaha, I don't know
Jake:啊是吧
Jake: Ah, is that it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈咱也不知道啊我是
Lucia: Hahaha, I have no idea either
Jake:108 在许多文化中
Jake: 108 in many cultures
Jake:108是个神圣的数字
Jake: 108 is a sacred number
Jake:象征着宇宙的和谐和完整
Jake: Symbolizing the harmony and completeness of the universe
Alice:啊是
Alice: Ah, right
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 啊真的吗
Lucia: Ah, really?
Jake:也也代表着
Jake: It also represents
Lucia: 我刚想到的是水浒里面的好汉
Lucia: I just thought of the 108 heroes from Water Margin
Jake:对就这个水浒宇宙的完整
Jake: Yes, the completeness of the Water Margin universe
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great
Shure: 水浒宇宙可还行
Shure: The Water Margin universe, really?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Alice:水浒宇宙
Alice: Water Margin universe
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:没问题吧
Jake: No problem, right?
Alice:没问题
Alice: No problem
Jake:没问题水
Jake: No problem, Water
Lucia: 没问题写万事皆可宇宙
Lucia: No problem, just write "anything goes universe"
Jake:水浒 宇宙
Jake: Water Margin universe
Lucia: 都是那两个漫画公司折腾出来的破事
Lucia: It's all the mess created by those two comic companies
Lucia: 不过我从我从高中开始看DC和漫威
Lucia: But I've been reading DC and Marvel since high school
Lucia: 然后一直看到现在
Lucia: And I've been reading them ever since
Lucia: 然后每天都每天都在
Lucia: And every day, every day
Shure: OK牛逼了家人们
Shure: OK, you rock, folks
Lucia: 就是精神股东
Lucia: Just a spiritual shareholder
Lucia: 和期待这两个公司破产的边缘摇摆
Lucia: And they are teetering on the brink of bankruptcy.
Lucia: 因为我觉得你们写出来那种狗屎故事
Lucia: Because I think the stories you guys write are such crap.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要不然还是别编了哈哈哈
Lucia: Maybe it's better if you don't make them up, haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's another one.
Jake:这个 197
Jake: This, 197.
Jake:这个数字代表1970年
Jake: This number represents the year 1970.
Jake:那一年首次庆祝的地球日
Jake: That's the year the first Earth Day was celebrated.
Jake:这个数字具有重要的历史和纪念意义
Jake: This number has significant historical and commemorative meaning.
Jake:看对不对
Jake: Is that right?
Lucia: 我估计他就是算准了
Lucia: I guess he figured it out.
Lucia: 有些东西你也不能确定
Lucia: Some things you can't be sure of.
Lucia: 所以他就在这乱说
Lucia: So he just makes stuff up.
Jake:对他就是乱说
Jake: Yeah, he just makes it up.
Jake:这个确实是真的 1970年
Jake: This one is true though, 1970.
Shure: 这是谁，一看就是大张伟唱的是吗
Shure: Who is this, it looks like Da Zhang Wei singing, right?
Shure: 怎么跟大张伟那死动静似的
Shure: How does it sound just like Da Zhang Wei?
Shure: 把这个大屏幕打开然后
Shure: Turn on the big screen and then...
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Shure: 想想地球日的题目
Shure: Think of a topic for Earth Day.
Jake:行啊来吧
Jake: Sure, go ahead.
Jake:谁有那什么账号
Jake: Who has that account?
Shure: 哎把那俩遥控器给我去
Shure: Hey, get me those two remote controls.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:遥控器是在这
Jake: The remote is here.
Jake:所以他开了是吧
Jake: So he turned it on, right?
Lucia: 问大家132为什么是回文书
Lucia: Ask everyone why 132 is a palindrome.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, oh.
Jake:问问他是吧
Jake: Ask him, right?
Lucia: 对就把这个做
Lucia: Yeah, make it a question.
Jake:我再问一下
Jake: I'll ask again.
Lucia: 不是把这个作为一个题目
Lucia: Not make it a topic.
Jake:哈哈哈让大家乱编
Jake: Haha, let everyone make stuff up.
Lucia: 对对对我可能会被全场人打神经病
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I might be called crazy by everyone.
Jake:人均GPT哈哈哈
Jake: Everyone's a GPT, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:人均GBT
Jake: Everyone's a GPT.
Jake:弱智吧
Jake: Are you stupid?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:我们要不就弱智娃
Jake: Should we just be dumb kids?
Jake:题目里面抽几个得了哈哈哈
Jake: Let's just randomly pick a few questions from the topic, haha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 我又想起来昨天那个北京是什么
Lucia: Oh, I just remembered that thing about Beijing from yesterday
Lucia: 我说直辖市
Lucia: I said it was a municipality
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 我没看到他指的那辆车
Lucia: I didn't see the car he was pointing at
Lucia: 我以为你
Lucia: I thought you
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:太典型了这个哈哈
Jake: This is so typical, haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 我以为你真的在正儿八经的问
Lucia: I thought you were really asking seriously
Jake:哈正儿八经的
Jake: Haha, seriously?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 所以对
Lucia: So yeah
Jake:问北京市
Jake: Asking about Beijing
Lucia: 然后我就没有感觉到这个问题的意义
Lucia: And then I just didn't get the point of the question
Jake:就送来一个正确的回答
Jake: Just give a correct answer
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 对啊这个肯定不会出错吧
Lucia: Yeah, you can't go wrong with that, right?
Lucia: 谁知道你问的是车呢
Lucia: Who knew you were asking about the car?
Jake:所以试试
Jake: So try
Jake:吧那个车
Jake: That car
Lucia: 不知道不了解
Lucia: No idea, don't know
Lucia: 就是有一个车牌子叫北京
Lucia: There's a car brand called Beijing
Lucia: 汽车厂牌
Lucia: It's an automobile brand
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
爱丽沙：哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:弱智吧那个什么陨石
Jake: Stupid, that meteor
Jake: ：为什么每次都能精准的打到陨石坑
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 现在是冷笑话时间了是
Lucia: Is it time for cold jokes now?
Shure: 哈哈太蠢了
Shure: Hahaha so dumb
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What's that?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 哎呦我受不了了
Shure: Oh, I can't take it
Shure: 卧槽太傻逼了
Shure: Damn, that's so stupid
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 怎么会如此
Tasha: How can it be like this?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:就是弱智吧
Jake: It's just idiotic, right?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else?
Jake:被门夹过的核桃还能
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:还能补脑吗
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:多少被门夹过
Jake:喝杯豆汁压压惊吧哈哈哈
Jake: Have a cup of fermented mung bean milk to calm down, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈我们是要给AI实施
Katrina: Ha, are we going to implement AI?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:哈没有没有
Jake: Ha, no, no
Jake:这个已经用起来了
Jake: It's already being used
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:就是AI里边就是有一个研究
Jake: So, in the AI, there is a study
Jake:就是说用弱智吧的这个数据做训练
Jake: that says using data from idiots for training
Shure: 我的
Shure: Oh my
Jake:然后效果比别人
Jake: And the results are better than others
Lucia: 然后的训练是不是20分钟一点
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哎
Jake: Hahaha, hey
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:你这个灯是没有了
Jake: Your light is gone.
Shure: 灯怎么变红了
Shure: Why did the light turn red?
Jake:啊红的
Jake: Ah, it's red.
Jake:没关系啊
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:要不你看一下手机对
Jake: Maybe check your phone, right?
Lucia: 我看一下
Jake:对你看一下啊这个
Jake: Yeah, check this.
Jake:手机软件
Jake: The phone app.
Alice:孕妇打人算群殴吗
Alice: If a pregnant woman hits someone, does it count as a group fight?
Alice:孕妇打人算群殴
Alice: Pregnant woman hitting someone counts as a group fight.
Katrina: 哈哈哈对
Katrina: Hahaha, right.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Haha, right.
Jake:这个点这个很点
Jake: This point, this point.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake:看看看看看你的这个状态
Jake: Look, look, look at your status.
Jake:他应该就是过热呀之类的
Jake: It should be overheating or something.
Alice:他肚子里有一个哈哈
Alice: There's a haha inside his belly.
Shure: 啊过热
Shure: Ah, overheating.
Jake:过热
Jake: Overheating.
Jake:嗯那你就come down
Jake: Yeah, then you should come down.
Jake:come down
Jake: Come down.
Shure: 我我come down好像呵呵
Shure: I, I come down, seems like, hehe.
Jake:哈哈哈你come down然后就
Jake: Hahaha, you come down and then just...
Lucia: 他给我提示说就是party停止
Lucia: 但是之前的这个已经没关系
Katrina: But before this, it was already fine.
Jake:哦没关系再开一个吧
Jake: Oh, it's fine, just start another one.
Lucia: 没有stop time.
Jake:没关系没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:早上好啊
Jake: Good morning.
Jake:你这还亮着吗
Jake: Is this still on?
Jake:你这一直不插电
Jake: You never plug it in.
Tasha: 亮着吗
Tasha: Is it on?
Jake:那当然不亮了
Jake: Of course it's not on.
Jake:你不插电
Jake: You don't plug it in.
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:可多了还有吃健胃消食片能吃饱吗
Jake: Can you really get full by eating digestive tablets?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 受不了了
Shure: I can't take it anymore.
Shure: 他怎么卡死了卧槽
Shure: Why is he frozen, damn it.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake:用这东西来训练AI的话
Jake: If you use this to train AI,
Jake:因为他要回答他就需要很多逻辑
Jake: it needs a lot of logic to answer.
Katrina: 就需要很多逻辑
Katrina: It needs a lot of logic.
Katrina: 真的需要很多逻辑
Katrina: It really needs a lot of logic.
Jake:真的是需要很多逻辑
Jake:你确定吗
Jake: Are you sure?
Katrina: 你确定吗
Katrina: Are you sure?
Jake:哈哈哈就是因为训练的时候
Jake: Haha, because during training,
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:会给他一个人写的答案
Jake: you give it an answer written by a person.
Jake:让人写答案
Jake: Have someone write an answer.
Jake:就是他会一本正经的去回答这个问题
Jake: It will answer seriously.
Jake:就是吃健胃消食片什么什么功效
Jake: Like, what are the effects of digestive tablets?
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Alice:笑死了
Alice: That's hilarious.
Jake:不孕不育会遗传吗
Jake: Is infertility hereditary?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈我受不了
Katrina: Haha, I can't take it.
Lucia: 到底是剩8.5条命还是剩4.5条命呢
Lucia: 算一下 7除以2不应该是3.5吗
Jake:有
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 猫有9条命
Jake:充电宝不剁了
Jake: The power bank is not cutting it.
Lucia: 哦我弱智
Katrina: 哎他说
Katrina: Hey, he said
Katrina: 地球上有30%的海洋
Katrina: the Earth has 30% ocean.
Katrina: 和百分之70%的海洋和30%的陆地
Katrina: And 70% ocean and 30% land.
Katrina: 那剩下的30%海洋和70%的陆地去哪了
Katrina: So, where did the remaining 30% of the ocean and 70% of the land go?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:啥 70%什么
Jake: What? 70% of what?
Lucia: 地球上有70%的海洋和30%的陆地
Alice: Earth has 70% ocean and 30% land.
Jake:地球上有70%的海洋和30%的陆地
Jake: Earth has 70% ocean and 30% land.
Alice:那剩下的30%海洋和70%的陆地去哪了
Alice: So where did the remaining 30% of the ocean and 70% of the land go?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:插电了吗
Jake: Is it plugged in?
Jake:好插个电啊
Jake: Alright, plug it in.
Katrina: 什么什么
Katrina: What? What?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Jake:完
Jake: Done.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
luxi :哈哈哈关羽不斩老幼
Lucia: 为什么不派老幼去斩杀关羽
Shure: 太傻逼了
Shure: That's so stupid.
Shure: 我受不了了
Shure: I can't take it.
Jake:哈哈这好好有
Jake: Haha, that's a good one.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈好有道理
Jake: Hahaha, that's so true.
Katrina: 哈明天给大家表演这个吧
Katrina: Haha, let's perform this for everyone tomorrow.
Jake:就出题吧
Jake: Let's come up with a question.
Jake:咱也别世界地球人
Jake: Let's not talk about the world and earth.
Jake:哈哈哈行
Jake: Hahaha, alright.
Jake:我明天表演的那个
Jake: What I'll perform tomorrow.
Jake:我明天表演的节目就是给大家讲笑话
Jake: My performance tomorrow will be telling jokes.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake:咱充上了吗
Jake: Is it charged?
Jake:咱要不开机
Jake: Let's turn it on.
Jake:又挂了是吧又挂了
Jake: It crashed again, didn't it?
Lucia: 写遗嘱的时候因为拖延错过了
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 那你怎么办
Katrina: 哈哈哈那真的是呆了
Jake:错过了再来
Jake: Missed it, try again.
Jake:然后然后出来问问题
Jake: Then come out and ask questions.
Lucia: 英语听力考试
Alice: P.E. listening test
Lucia: 总是听到两个人在广播里唠嗑
Lucia: 干扰我做题
Alice: It distracts me from doing the test
Lucia: 怎么能把那两个人撵走
Alice: How can I get rid of those two people
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 找不到这个
Shure: Can't find this
Tasha: 充的没有用的快
Katrina: Hurry, it's useless, hurry
Jake:正正月剪头被舅舅制止并暴打一顿
Jake: Cutting hair in the first month of the lunar year was stopped by his uncle and got beaten up
Lucia: 给谁
Lucia: For whom
Jake:舅舅舅是否得逞后正当防卫
Jake: Did his uncle act in self-defense after his success
Shure: 啊还有那个
Shure: Ah, there's that too
Jake:哈哈哈啥啥啥
Jake: Hahaha what what what
Shure: 那个
Shure: That one
Lucia: 这样问我想20
Lucia: Asking like this, I think 20
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 舅舅那个正月剪头不是死舅舅吗
Shure: Isn't cutting hair in the first month of the lunar year bad luck for uncles?
Shure: 然后如果呢
Shure: And if
Shure: 我正月烫头的话
Shure: I perm my hair in the first month
Shure: 那舅舅会变弯吗哈哈哈
Shure: Will my uncle become bent? Haha 性别问题
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈救命
Alice:今年过年的时候
Alice: This year during the New Year
Alice:真的就有这个正月剪头的
Alice: There really was someone who cut their hair in the first month
Alice:然后他舅舅他舅妈把他侄子给起诉了
Alice: And his uncle and aunt sued his nephew
Tasha: 啊起诉
Tasha: Ah, sued
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Jake:对OK
Jake: Yes, OK
Alice:因为觉得就是他剪头让他老公死了
Alice: Because they thought cutting his hair caused her husband to die
Tasha: 他老公真的死了
Tasha: Her husband really died?
Katrina: 这么容易死啊
Tasha: 真的很容易死
Tasha: It's really easy to die
Katrina: 这么容易死要了也没用
Katrina: If it's that easy, it's useless anyway
Alice:然后他舅妈真的把他给起诉
Alice: And his aunt really sued him
Katrina: 之前你看过那个台湾的那个综艺没有
Katrina: Did you see that Taiwanese variety show before
Katrina: 说有一个女生说什么什么打耳洞
Katrina: Where a girl talked about getting her ears pierced
Katrina: 哪边打耳洞
Katrina: Which side to pierce
Katrina: 什么克老公
Katrina: Something about it cursing her husband
Katrina: 呵呵那人说老公这么容易死
Katrina: Haha, they say husbands die so easily.
Katrina: 要老公干什么
Katrina: What's the point of having a husband?
Katrina: 没看过那个搞笑的吗超搞笑
Katrina: Haven't you seen that funny one? It's super funny.
Jake:好呀
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我看一看哦
Jake: Let me take a look.
Katrina: 已读乱回
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 嗯呵呵呵呵
Katrina: Hmm, hehehe
Tasha: 我有罪对不起
Alice:早知道最后被第三志愿录取
Alice: If I had known, I would've gotten into my third choice.
Alice:第三志愿应该填清华了
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈啊哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 太傻逼了
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Tasha: 说不出话来
Tasha: 那你就可能被第4自愿录取了
Tasha: Then you might be the 40th person to get accepted.
Jake:都收波眼镜
Jake: Everyone, grab your glasses.
Jake:然后倒完咱就走啊
Jake: Once we're done, let's head out.
Tasha: 哦那我不连了啊
Tasha: Oh, then I won't connect it.
Jake:那我不连了啊
Jake: Then I won't connect it either.
Jake:当时没连哦
Jake: It wasn't connected at the time.
Jake:你不连了故意的
Jake: You didn't connect it on purpose.
小薇 ：定是上天的安排
Tasha: It must be fate.
Jake:哈哈关关关关掉
Jake: Haha, turn it off, turn it off, turn it off.